[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt ich hab ich versprochen zeigen wie
ich meine unterwasserwelt deko
hergestellt habe ich habe leider in dem
ganzen stress vergessen mit zu filmen
wie ich die korallen und die alten und
so weiter gefilmt gemacht habe und wie
ich der taucher hergestellt habe und
später eben auch wie ich die torte
dekoriert habe das war einfach ich hab
nur noch drei tage zeit gehabt ich
musste die torte fertigbringen das
wetter war so heißt der von ist gerissen
es war einfach so ein großes chaos
deswegen wollte ich doch die kamera
einfach gar nicht mehr mitlaufen lassen
deswegen habe ich jetzt nachhinein noch
mal gefilmt um euch zu zeigen wie ich
die korallen und die alten hergestellt
habe und jetzt heute abend habe ich
jetzt auch ganz spontan wie ich es sehen
könnt noch mal eine taube hergestellt
einfach dass das ganze komplett ist und
ihr wisst wie ihr so eine
unterwasserwelt deko herstellen könnt
jetzt zeige ich euch am besten zuerst
mal wie man den taucher macht und später
eben wie man die korallen macht einfach
weiter taucher so das aufwendigste am
ganzen ist ich habe jetzt für den
taucher insgesamt so etwa 50 minuten
gebraucht falls ihr also etwas die
überzeit geht's eben ein bisschen
schneller wenn ihr etwas länger braucht
es auch kein problem
besser ist natürlich auch immer wenn ihr
zwischen den einzelnen schritten die
sachen trocknen lässt
das heißt wenn ihr jetzt gleich den kopf
herstellt können an den ruhig und
abtrocknen lassen und danach
weitermachen
das vereinfacht eigentlich so ziemlich
die ganze arbeit und macht es nicht so
mühsam ihr werdet nämlich gleich sehen
dass ich da auch so ein bisschen rum
machen musste mit den haaren
aber jetzt eigentlich einfach mal wie
man eben den taucher erstellt und danach
sage ich dann kostet hier habe ich jetzt
meine modelliermasse die eben zu 50
prozent aus von dort zu 50 prozent aus
blüten passte besteht
die muss jetzt richtig gut durchkneten
wie es sehe ich das am anfang ziemlich
mühsam die stand jetzt ein paar tage bei
zimmertemperatur bei zimmertemperatur
lässt sich einfacher verarbeiten
als ich las man von dann auch auf uns so
bei zimmertemperatur der stadt ist ja
nicht kaputt gegangen gekauften von dann
könnt ihr nämlich auch bei
zimmertemperatur lagern
dann ist nämlich auch der kühlschrank
immer so voll
mustique ist einfach wir durch das
kneten jemand geschmeidiger wird meine
hände fette ich ab und zu mit familien
ein zwischenhalt und gibt es eigentlich
in jedem supermarkt zu kaufen
ein taucher hat ja einen taucheranzug an
deswegen braucht ihr in hautfarbe
eigentlich nur den kopf die hände und
ein bisschen was von den füßen da nehme
ich mir jetzt einfach so eine menge weg
bisschen mehr lieber ein bisschen mehr
als zu wenig den rest praktisch wieder
weg und jetzt mische ich mir meine
hautfarbe aus gelb rot und braun und wer
hat kann noch so ein elfenbeinturm
nehmen
das trifft nämlich ganz gut und da
müsste jetzt einfach eine kleine menge
heraus nehmen lieber erstmal weniger und
später noch mal nach verden ein bisschen
rot ein bisschen braun dass die figur
nicht so rosa thron hat wie weil ein
schweinchen hätte ich meine hände noch
mal gut ein
ihr könnt auch handschuhe tragen aber
das mache ich irgendwie ungern weil es
dann die ganze zeit klebt und die farbe
geht ja auch ganz gut wieder raus von
den händen von daher es selbst nicht so
schlimm
jetzt nehme ich mir hier styroporplatten
zur hilfe die habe ich mit alufolie
eingeleitet das war dann praktisch so
einer tollen einstellung
hier habe ich zahnstocher drinnen
einfach um das oberen im unteren zu
verbinden
außerdem richten
stefan jetzt muss dazu erst mal den kopf
formen und dazu nehmt ihr euch je
nachdem wie groß ihr leben haben wollte
eine menge weg damit ihr aber eine
vorstellung habt wie groß das hier bei
mir wert messe ich euch einmal die kugel
ab und zwar sind das so etwa dreieinhalb
zentimeter
[Musik]
den rest packe ich jetzt weg damit er
nicht austrocknet und die form der jetzt
schon zu einer kugel muss schön rund
sein ohne irgendwelche risse einfach
zwischen den händen oder auf der
arbeitsfläche wenn ihr das zwischen
händen nicht könnt so als rundherum
keine risse und jetzt wir möchte ich
halten etwas längeren kopf deswegen
freue mich den zwischen den händen zu
seinem ein und legt einfach mal kurz ab
so dass es ein bisschen ab antrocknen
kann also ein bisschen antrocknen lassen
und jetzt nehme ich mir einen
zahnstocher oder einen schaschlikspieß
wenn jetzt denn mit etwas zucker kleber
und steckt denn hier rein
also wenn ihr wollt ist der stab hier
unten länger ist als die torte hoch
genug ist dann nimmt einen
schaschlikspieß und schneidet den
zurecht für mich reicht es jetzt aber so
[Musik]
und jetzt gehe ich hier einfach zu
meinen styropor ted und steckt es hier
rein und so kann besetzt da schön
antrocknen und ich kann eben daran
weiter arbeiten damit ich jetzt das euch
zu zeigen dann steckt man da oben rein
und da steckte am besten flach und jetzt
könnt ihr hier schön den kopf noch
fertig stellen
ich nehme jetzt dazu so eine ganz kleine
kugel hab die eben gewohnt dann das wird
die nase dann suche ich mir hier die
mitte noch etwas zu verkleben auf nicht
so vieles bedenken dass überall da und
zucker kleber ist man es auch später
sieht mal das schön glänzt und befestige
tester hier ganz einfach ein bisschen
knifflig bei so kleinen dingen und
einfach antworten dann hat der gute mann
nämlich schon eine nase für die augen
nehme ich mir ein weißes stück und macht
erstmal schön weich
davor mich eine kleine kugel und
halbiere sie jetzt wieder beides zu
einer kugel formen und etwas flach
drücken
und dann könnte auch gleich schauen ob
sie gleich groß sind dass hier ein
bisschen größer
so sind sie gleich und dann gebe ich
wieder etwas zucker kleber auf den kopf
und ich möchte dass die augen wie in der
mitte sind
ich finde es sieht immer ein bisschen
lustiger aus kann die dann einfach hier
so ankleben
und dann hab das schon ein gesicht mit
nase und augen
jetzt fehlen da noch die ohren
dazu nehme ich mal wieder ein kleines
hautfarbenes stück nicht so groß
kommst du nach google also ich sehe die
kugel ist immer so
die ausgangsform für alles und nichts
erteile die das mache ich einfach um die
kugeln dann möglichst gleich groß zu
machen gelingt natürlich nicht immer
dann nehme ich hier mein werkzeug mein
ball tour und drückte hier diesen
kleinen ball da rein dann sieht es so
aus dass gleiche hier noch mal und dann
benutze ich den hier an der seite mit
kleber und drücke das an der seite an
da könnt ihr euch dann gern irgendein
werkzeug nehmen was euch hilft es daran
zu befestigen
manchmal krebs nämlich enger an den
händen als am kopf da könnte auch ganz
gerne zahnstocher nehmen und bis an den
kopf dran zu drücken
das gleiche auf der anderen seite die
seite mit kleber benutzen und andrücken
und dann noch schauen ob es auf gleicher
höhe sind so dass ich das jetzt einfach
kurz antrocknen und über mich in der
zeit schon mal um die kennenlernen dafür
nehme ich mir wieder ein stück
modelliermasse das hat jetzt einen
durchmesser von zweieinhalb zentimeter
formen des zu einer rolle
ich möchte jetzt nur die hände
modellieren also ohne arme weil er der
taucher später einen taucheranzug haben
wird und man praktisch dann nur die
hände sieht ohne arme sollte dann so
etwas zentimeter dick sein
dann können dass halbiert hier arbeite
ich jetzt ganz gerne parallel einfach
damit die hände gleich groß werden
ich fange aber jetzt mal mit dem einen
an jetzt müsst euch praktisch vorstellen
die hand hatte eine breitere fläche
rises handgelenk und als der arm
deswegen ich möchte hier fordert die
hand formen und hier soll es eben
richtung tauchanzug gehen
deswegen freue mich dass hier hinten
jetzt etwas dünner zwischen den fingern
in etwa das gleiche auch hier
dann wird es einmal flach gedrückt und
jetzt könnte in dem stadium auch schon
mal schauen ob es von der proportion her
stimmt also sollte ungefähr so das
gesicht bedecken so wie eben bei uns
menschen auch so sieht es dann aus jetzt
schneidet ihr hier den daumen ein
und da müsste jetzt aufpassen und zwar
stellt euch vor hier die fläche ist er
ungefähr so ein kreis hier an der seite
ist der daumen und da oben die finger
das heißt ihr müsst ihr den daumen
einschneiden
so macht es am besten parallel direkt
auch beim anderen die fläche her
schneidig weg
jetzt könnt ihr schon die form erahnen
das heißt die handflächen sind jetzt
geöffnet nach oben
so und jetzt dürft ihr nicht bis hier
runter schneiden sondern müsst weiter
oben ansetzen und dreimal einschneiden
damit ihr eben vier finger erhaltet 11
und jetzt kann es zum beispiel wie hier
sein dass hier der kleine finger zu dick
ist dann schneidet hier das stück noch
weg und schneidet den kleinen finger und
dem ringfinger auch kürze das gleiche
auch hier und jetzt geht es praktisch
nur noch darum dass ihr eben hier die
ecken und kanten rausbekommt und da
rollt ihr einfach hier mit den fingern
ein bisschen hin und her dass die
spitzen verschwinden und die
schnittflächen
könnte auch gern mal umdrehen
und wenn ihr merken finger ist zu dick
dann schneidet ihnen einfach etwas
dünner
das gleiche auch hier
und falls ihr zu lange wir modellieren
braucht dann müsste die andere hand
ebenso lange abdecken mit folie damit
sie euch nicht abtrocknet sonst könnt
ihr nämlich nicht mehr modellieren
modelliermasse trocknet nämlich auch
ziemlich schnell durch die blüten passt
um durch das cnc und da oben vor mich
einfach so eine kleine spitze das werdet
ihr dann gleich sehen wie sie es gibt
auch leute die mitmachen da gern
fingernägel drauf das können damit zu
einer lotterie machen die schlechter da
oben so ein bisschen ein kinderprojekt
stief fingernägel 1 tanzen beim daumen
aufpassen der ich ja dann da außen dann
habt ihr nämlich auch so ein bisschen
ein fingernagel effekt jetzt könnte je
nachdem wie wir es was ihr später mit
den händen machen wollt die hände noch
formen dass sie nicht so platt darlegen
ich möchte zum beispiel dass die eine
hand etwas hält deswegen gehe ich die
ein mann herum
da könnte dann zum beispiel so ein
modell ihr stab dazwischen legen und bei
der hand möchte ich später dass sie
winkt also so praktisch das handgelenk
weg bieten und zum trocknen lege ich das
hier drauf von alleine wird die haben
nicht so bleiben deswegen muss man die
bisschen abstützen
die haben genau so könnte auch so
bauklötzchen nehmen einfach dagegen
drücken in die form die er haben möchte
weiter gehts jetzt mit dem gesicht da
mal ich mir jetzt mit lebensmittelfarben
noch die augen auf ich möchte dass das
ein bisschen mehr lustige figur wird
deswegen sollten rasch ihren ich finde
es mal anzüge
da können es zum beispiel auch
augenbrauen und normalerweise würde ich
den hund hin malen aber weil dieser ein
taucher werden soll bekommt er das
mundstück von dieser sauerstoffflasche
wenn ich jetzt mund malen würde würde
ich den zumal dass er eben einfach so
lacht oder keine ahnung könnt ihr auch
wein ins gesicht machen wir eben volt
und für das mundstück für ein taucher
nehme ich mir schwarzen schwarze
modelliermasse frauen die zu einer kugel
und dann gehe ich hier etwas kleber
drauf und klebt einfach die kugel
dagegen und drückst du zu flach und
stand wirklich da noch eine kleinere
kugel obendrauf einfach dass es ein
bisschen lebendiger aussieht so könnt
ihr übrigens auch schneller herstellen
wenn die kleine babys modellieren wollt
jetzt könntet ihr turnier wollen
links und rechts noch den ansatz vom und
malen
dann hab da trotzdem den lächelnden
tauchen jetzt fehlen dem taucher oder
taucherin noch die haare
deswegen stecke ich den jetzt lassen wir
noch dran
ich zeige euch jetzt erstmalig die haare
machen die möchte ich jetzt aus gelber
mutter lehmacher machen
bei meiner tochter hatte ich hatte die
figur braune haare soll es auch gelbe
haare bekommen also blonde und das mache
ich hier' knoblauchpresse ich stecke da
meine modelliermasse rein
es gibt auch ganz bestimmte geräte dafür
super dann heißen die glaube ich und da
kann man dann verschiedene strukturen
rauslassen
ich presse es aber jetzt durch die
knoblauchpresse und da könnte dann auch
immer wieder nachschieben so dass die
haare länger werden
und dann schneit oder die einfach weg da
könnte auch zwei farben mischen dafür
dass die haare so ein bisschen ein
effekt bekommen und jetzt muss ich mir
hier einfach so einzelne strähnen ab
damit sich das gleich besser verarbeiten
lässt
ich nehme ich mir meine figur und gäbe
etwas kleber auf der rückseite des
kopfes und auch auf die oberseite
es reicht wenn ihr so die fläche hier
bedeckt weiter unten interessiert und so
keinen für die figur reichte sitz
komplett und dann fangt ihr an
hier unten das anzukleben und die haare
sollten jetzt von unten nach oben
geklebt werden weil ihr die haare im
wasser nach oben fliegen nach oben
schwimmen kann also die erste tour
umdrehen
und damit es besser hebt lege ich mir da
so ein holzklötzchen dahinter habe ich
etwas knifflig da kam aber jetzt
und die anderen haare klebt er dann
praktisch da oben fest so hat auch die
bülent ceylan figur gemacht
mit den flügen auch die haare bisschen
hoch und damit es hier besseren halt hat
auch hier etwas kleber zwischen rhein
[Musik]
einfach trocknen
den brauche ich ja dann erst wieder
menschen auf die torte setzen will
jetzt kümmere ich mich mal um die arme
und um die flossen die flossen mache ich
jetzt einfach mit gelb weil ich finde
das ganz gut passt da nehme ich mir
jetzt ein stück modelliermasse das hat
etwa 300 cm durchmesser
wenn ihr zu viel fett an den händen habt
dann können wir keine schönen kugeln
formen
das heißt probiert immer erst mal mit
etwas weniger die kugel halt bier ich
mir dann ganz gut lässt licht auf rollen
weil einfach holz so eine struktur hat
die dann eben verhindert dass euch das
die ganze zeit weggerutscht und das
nimmt auch so ein bisschen das fett von
den händen jetzt vorm ich die kugel
etwas länglich aber nicht so nach rolle
sondern eher zu einem tropfen
aber hinten nicht so spitz und dann
beginne ich damit den tropfen flach zu
drücken
aber schön in die länge zu gehen
hinten nicht darf nicht so flach er
vorne
nach vorne hin breiter werden
wieso ein enden fuß oder wie ebenso eine
flosse aussieht und auch da wieder auf
die proportionen achten zwischen hände
und gesicht
die flossen müssen ja länger sein und
größer sein als die hände und eben auch
weil ich draußen ja größer sein als die
füße den zweiten dann auch
[Musik]
und da nehme ich meinen ball tool dem
diesmal mit der großen mit dem großen
loch und steche hier einmal ein so hier
auch nicht zu tief dann habe ich auch
deswegen gerade noch reingemacht sie
jetzt die flosse doch noch mal ein
bisschen in die länge und stritt sich
damit der messe rückseite noch so einen
kleinen streifen ein
auch auf der rückseite
jetzt nehme ich mir eine kleine kugel
hautfarbene modelliermasse jetzt nehme
ich mir eine kleine kugel aus
hautfarbener modelliermasse die hat
ungefähr 15 cm durchmesser die form ich
jetzt zu einer langen rolle hat ungefähr
zentimeter jetzt im durchmesser also
halte ich das jetzt einmal und formen
das hier auch schön das wird praktisch
das kleine stück bein was man dann
zwischen flosse und taucheranzug sieht
das ende muss etwas ausgedünnt werden
beiden und dann kommt jetzt etwas kleber
in die flosse da steckte dann
diese rolle rein ich finde ich ein
bisschen zu lang ich mache sie doch noch
ein bisschen kürzer und dann könnte es
da fest drücken braucht auch noch die
beine die aus dem wasser raus gucken da
nehme ich jetzt schwarze modelliermasse
weil der tauchanzug schwarz sein soll
die kugel hat einen durchmesser von 82
metern vor mich zu einer langen rolle
und die machte aber einfach so groß eben
je nachdem wie viel bein ihr raus gucken
lassen wollte einmal halbieren und hier
vorne wieder schön formen die gerade
schnittkante kann ruhig gerade bleiben
und hier auf der anderen seite auf der
kundenseite gehe ich mit meinem
rollstuhl rein und kleines stück und
weil jetzt ein loch mit dem board wohl
viel zu groß wäre nehme ich mir hier so
ein anderes werkzeug ich glaube das
heißt mit knochen wachsen und stellt
damit ein kleines loch ein indem ich das
so hin und her bewegen
gleich auf der anderen seite ein stechen
hin und her bewegen so dass das so dass
der rand etwas ausgedünnt wird und dann
kommt da viel kleber rein und da kommt
jetzt die schlosserei
und weil es ja später er schiebt aus dem
wasser gucken soll müsste das dann hier
auch tief einschneiden darauf achten hin
zur spitze schräg einschneiden und damit
die flossen jetzt etwas lebendiger
aussehen wie ich die mir hier noch so
zurecht wie hier auch einfach
zurechtbiegen klappt besser wenn die
flossen etwas dünner sinnig hatte die
beim einem topf auf der torte auch
dünner
also macht die lieber düne und dann
könnt ihr euch diesen widerstand gegen
stellen
dann bleibt die auch in der form und
weil ihr die später in die torte stecken
wollt müsst ihr jetzt noch einen
zahnstocher nehmen den mit kleber
benetzen und hier einmal ein stechen
und dann könnte die so trocknen lassen
olic fehlen sind taucher nur noch die
arme
dazu habe ich noch mal schwarze blüten
passte weil es eben der tauchanzug ist
die hat die kugel hat einen durchmesser
von 4 cm und es ist relativ einfach und
zwar rollt ihr daraus einen strang
ziemlich gleichmäßig ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach die einfachste methode in
der mitte kommt der kopf drauf und das
sind dann praktisch die arme so und
jetzt macht er hier das gleiche einfach
hier mit diesem werkzeug ein stechen
eine mulde formen
und jetzt müsste einfach gucken wie ihr
die arme haben wollte das heißt die
torte wird denke ich mal zweistöckig
auch bei euch eure einstöckig geht ja
auch und nehme mal an dass wir die
torten randhir dann würde ich hier
würden hier die arme rausgucken
vielleicht so in der höhe
das heißt ich lege mir da etwas darunter
am besten hier auch sein bauklötzchen
und meine rechte hand hier soll er dann
winken
das heißt ich bin mir hier den arm nach
oben und stelle da was davor einfach
abstützen und die andere hand die soll
er später was halten das heißt die caro
ich so irgendwie auf dem boden was
suchen
und da kann ich jetzt auch direkt die
hand einstecken und festkleben
gar nicht so ablegen müssen so reicht
auch ich hoffe ihr könnt euch diese
sollen etwa vorstellen wie es später
aussehen wird diese flossen werden so in
die karte gesteckt
die andere parallelen so und dann müsst
ihr praktisch den bauch kopf hier nicht
wackeln dass dann der körper so verläuft
das heißt der kopf muss in etwa hier
sitzen und die schultern dann eben hier
ich kann euch das jetzt natürlich noch
nicht zusammen bauen weil die figuren
sind aber ich kann euch das mal so hin
schieben und dann wäre praktisch hier
noch der kopf drauf auf einmal zeigen
den müsste dann später einfach hier ein
stechen und mit etwas kleber befestigen
und dann habt ihr im prinzip auch schon
die figuren fertig und wie gesagt haben
könnte daran noch was einstecken
vielleicht eine blume oder ein seestern
oder eine alge oder keine ahnung ein
stück von einer koralle und könnte es
dann praktisch so auf der torte
platzieren
ihr kampf figuren aus modelliermasse
oder aus blüten passte trocknen lassen
das gibt zwei drei wochen
am besten ist wirklich immer wenn sie
richtig stein hat durchgetrocknet sind
das heißt wenn ihr wisst ich mache in
der monat eine motiv torte dann können
jetzt einen monat vorher schon mal die
figuren herstellen einfach an der luft
trocknen lassen und wenn sie dann
trocken sind können dass sie in kartons
verpacken und einfach bei raumtemperatur
oder in den kühlen keller aufbewahren
ich habe zb immer noch die figuren von
samir als erster geburtstagstorte das
ist jetzt fast wie lange ist es zwei
jahre her und die habe ich einfach nicht
wegschmeißen können ich muss dir einen
drauf heben dabei wenigstens nie so der
typ daraus aufhebt wie gesagt ihr können
sowas aufheben
ein paar wochen vorher herstellen dann
habt ihr tag des backens nicht mehr so
viel arbeit und jetzt gebe ich euch
einfach noch so ein paar anregungen wie
ihr korallen und allen herstellen könnt
und wie das jetzt eben geht zeige ich
euch im nächsten schritt die korallen
hab ich ja in allen möglichen farben
gemacht und jetzt zeige ich euch mal
sich die gemacht habe das ist nämlich
ganz ganz einfach ich nehme da ein stück
blüten passte knetet sie gut durch die
habe ich jetzt schon vorher eingefärbt
das schön weich knicken wenn ihr die
blüten paste aus dem kühlschrank holt
und sie verarbeiten wollte da ist ja
noch ziemlich kalt
ihr könnt sie dann aber für 23 sekunden
bei niedrigster stufe in die mikrowelle
stellen damit sie einfach gestaltet wird
jetzt einfach den ausrutscher
das geht mit so einem nudelholz perfekt
[Applaus]
das hier ist einer von tupperware einer
aus silikon den gesagt es noch besser
blüten passte könnt ihr übrigens auch
ganz gut mit einer nudelmaschine ganz
schön ausholen
grad wenn ihr größerer mengen machen
wollen müsste es nicht mit dem nudelholz
machen lebe ich mir das hier einfach hin
weiter hoch gesteht ich habe meine
unterlage leider schon zerschnitten
aber macht jetzt nix das möchte ich dass
der untere rand glatt wird also gerade
wird schneit es hier mit meinem roller
schneider aus und die form finde ich
jetzt an sich schon mal gar nicht so
schlecht und jetzt geht's einfach ganz
einfach indem durchaus später in
verschiedenen größen runde
ich hab ihnen runden keks ausstellte
hier habe ich eine kochschule eine
spritze die hat auch ein kleines noch
und ich hätte mir oft zu deckel auf von
irgendwelchen sprühflaschen mache ich
hier oben mal eine große ställe weg und
arbeite jetzt meist aber nur noch mit
dem jetzt müsste einfach überall so
kleine und große löcher rein bauern und
dann entsteht eben dieser korallen
effekt wie an einem korallenriff gerne
auch hier unten
noch schöner
und dann auch mit dem kleinsten
ausstecher schöne löcher einbauen
das kann total unregelmäßig sein
dann sieht es nämlich eine fehlen
natürlich heraus und damit es hier jetzt
nicht einfach so flach trocknet lebens
mit stück anträge wenn ihr mehr koran
machen wollt nehmt euch gleichen
größeres und ist falls ich mir einfach
kleine rillen und legt es hier
und dann könnte es schön in form legen
wenig es richtig rund haben wollt könne
dass du dich ist überwunden gegenstand
legen dann ist es später auch schön
geboren und kann sich heute schön an
für das nächste teilchen frau habe ich
rote blüten passte benutzt ja auch die
arbeitsfläche schön mit palmen
einstreichen und dünn ausrollen
[Musik]
hier brauche ich gerade streifen und die
können auch gerne als die müssen nicht
so parallel laufen sondern können gerne
nach hinten raus dicker werden
anfang und ende auch wegschneiden das
mache ich jetzt mal auf cloud damit ihr
das gut sehen könnt jetzt werde ich das
einmal aufhören und zwar von der großen
seite zur kleine
und hier könnt ihr gerne noch etwas
kleber reihen stehen damit fest bleibt
aber uns euch jetzt zeigen reicht es und
jetzt wollt ihr das schön weiter
zwischen den finger oder auch gern auf
der arbeitsfläche dass es wieder etwas
dünner wird und so erzählt ja auch den
effekt dass hier oben diese schnecke
schön deutlich wird und dann einfach in
der mitte teilen oder eine seite länger
oder kürzer und es waren bei mir so die
stehenden schweizer es ist ja
irgendwelche unter wasser pflanzen
die lasse ich einfach im liegen trocknen
und die werden dann später mit etwas
zucker kleber oder racing an der torte
befestigt was ihr auch machen könnt ist
das hier in dem durch ein stück blüten
passte und nachts ohne kleine wurst die
drück dir etwas flach und roller 23 mal
ein ausbaustopp drüber so dass es schon
noch etwas dick bleibt und jetzt könnt
ihr das hier von der seite her aufrollen
gerne ausdrücken raten liegen und dann
unten wegdrücken und dann habt ihr auch
hier so kleine pflänzchen für unter
wasser
das andere das hatte ich jetzt mit lena
gemacht aber ich zeige es euch einmal in
roth nehmen dazu aber meine blaue
unterlage ich habe mir ein kleines stück
abgemacht zu einer kugel gerollt und
dann die kugel zu einer langen wurst
und jetzt können die wurst auch noch
mitteilen
[Applaus]
unternehmt ihr euch so einen ball da
hier oben und kleinen und unten in
großen ball hat und mit diesem ball tour
habe ich jetzt hier oben eingestochen
und einfach 23 mal so hin und her und
dann noch mal dann entsteht hier so was
und dann einfach zwischen den finger
nochmal etwas dünner rollen
das mache ich jetzt hier auch nochmal
einfach mit dem ball her ein bisschen
das loch öffnen hin und her rollen
und dann könnt ihr das mit superkleber
hirschen aneinander kleben und
aufstellen und hab dann diese korallen
die ich auf meine torte mit lila gemacht
habe
am besten klebt ihr die dann mit etwas
zucker kleber zusammen
dann halten sie besser und dadurch auch
immer ganz schön wenn sie nicht gleich
post in das heißt wenn die große und
kleine habt dann zieht es viel besser
und wir natürlich aus
die algen waren sie ziemlich das
einfachste handelt heute dazu habe ich
mir ein stück grüne blüten passte
genommen
jetzt können das auf zwei verschiedene
arten machen entweder mit einem
nudelholz oder miteinander die maschine
erst zeigt solche besser nudelholz
einfach das stück schön dünn ausrollen
schönes langes stück und könnt euch
jetzt lange streifen abschneiden
entweder mit seinem roller oder in ihren
branchen lineal und trennt euch die
schön sauber ab und einmal wegschneiden
und dann ist ganz einfach das wirbeltier
die einfach um die eigene achse und
lasst es so abkühlen ausdrucken und weil
sie so nicht halten
nehmen wir euch auch für eine ein stück
alufolie nichts daraus und quetscht so
ein bisschen 1 und hier mehr algen daran
kommen umso besser hält das ganze
ich finde es mir zu dünnen alten auf
schönsten einfach so da einlegen
und da machte dann auch schöne dinge und
lange halten und verschiedene längen
dann sieht das ganze viel viel natürlich
aus und die könnte dann auch schön
nebeneinander machen und hier rein
quetschen
das gleiche ziel meter nudelmaschine ich
bin uns daher meine kitchenette
nudelmaschine die wird hier einfach
eingeschaltet wenn die blüten passt sich
oben rein und damit uns klebt tue ich
sie jetzt etwas stärker bestäuben stand
einmal durch
und dann immer wieder etwas stärker ich
möchte mich nicht dass die an meiner
maschine kleben bleibt und dann dünner
werden
das geht aber natürlich auch mit einer
nudelmaschine timo rieth anzukurbeln
muss ich kurz den ortswechsel und hier
nehme ich jetzt meinen tag lehrstelle
aufsatz dass die maschine laufen und
dann schneidet die maschine schöne
erstreiten
kritisch sieht übrigens so aus hat hier
so kleine schneidezähne die eben dann
die ganze platte in kleine scheiben
schneidet und dann macht euch jetzt
gleiche wie eben manuell mit der hand
auch da könnt ihr jetzt zum beispiel es
einfach so halbieren und dann wie schon
vollen gezeigt entgegen zwerge hinlegen
und trocken lassen
also das war nicht mal so einfach basics
wie gesagt habe ich vergessen euch zu
zeigen wie ich dann die torte eben
dekoriert habe aber wir gesehen haben
zweistöckige torte oben war so eine
kartei das ist der gleiche zeit wie bei
dem zitronenkuchen wir waren zitronen
wird sich ohne worte
nur habe ich eben statt des zitronensaft
einfach nur ali kur genommen
das macht den teig schön locker und
flockig die creme warne quark sahne
creme und da hatte ich auch großen
stücke drin wenn ihr wort kann ich euch
das mal als rezept posten aber im
prinzip ist eine ganz einfache quark
sahne creme über eine ganz normale
zitronen und orte das rezept habe ich
euch der bereits als video gepostet und
ja die torte habe ich dann eben
zusammengesetzt das habt ihr gesehen und
dann habe ich die deko mit etwas zucker
kleber und wird es zu etwas realizing
aufgeklebt das rezept für racing gibt es
in meinem nutella keks video da können
danach schauen und beim nächsten mal
werde ich wieder versuchen mit zu finden
wie ich den torte komplett herstellen
aber dass ich einfach immer so viel
aufwand und ich bin dann irgendwann
einfach froh wenn es fertig ist gerade
wenig da unter zeitdruck steht
aber ich werde mal eine torte nur für
euch machen und dann nehme ich mir die
zeit zum filmen dann klappt es auch mit
sicherheit jetzt wünsche ich euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen ich hoffe ich
konnte euch mit dem video helfen wenn
ich machen ein paar von euch eine
unterwasser mädels torte vielleicht habt
ihr noch bessere ideen
ich hatte zum beispiel
eine zeit mehr fischer herzustellen
normalerweise fahren dass ich noch ein
paar fische modelliert aber die könnten
auch theoretisch aufmalen also dass in
der kreativität wirklich keine grenzen
gesetzt
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen ich gehe zum paar tage zu
meiner schwester und mich dann danach
meter bei euch mit einem game ins spiel
was ich euch versprochen habe dazu werde
ich noch ein paar sachen einkaufen ein
paar sachen habe ich schon geschickt
bekommen und da freue ich mich schon
ganz arg drauf also macht gut und ist
als kiss
[Musik]